so you want to start a youtube channel
and you have decided that this is your
year maybe you've gone to youtube
already you've watched videos on how to
actually start but you want to know the
secrets to youtube success well rather
than googling your eyes out trying to
find this information i've brought to
you two amazing youtubers who have
reached over 100 000 subscribers and
we're going to break down 10 things that
we wish we knew if we were starting a
youtube channel this year well my name
is heather torres and you are watching
the youtube made simple show the show
where we go to overcome your fears gain
confidence on camera and create a
thriving youtube channel with your
message and actually this show
right now is brought to you by our
youtube 1k challenge i'll share more
information about that with you during
today's episode but i want to introduce
you to the two content creators that we
have with me today the first one is
lauren lauren is a cancer survivor as a
child and she knows the importance of
living in the moment that's why at the
age of 27 lauren quit her cushy job as a
research scientist to pursue a career in
music when laura was 16 her very own
mother told her sister not to buy her a
guitar because she would waste it well
lauren decided she was going to teach
herself how to play the guitar on her
own and in 2010 lauren decided to give a
shot at entrepreneurship and started
teaching voice and guitar lessons out of
a space out of a spare bedroom in her
small apartment in boston massachusetts
she had zero teaching experience but
knew that that was what she needed to do
she has taught on youtube now and now
has a channel that's over 100 000
subscribers lauren welcome to the
youtube made simple show hey how's it
going thanks for having me i'm so
excited that you're here we're going to
get into 10 tips but i want to introduce
our other
co-creator today and that creator is
andrew tui did i say that right andrew i
hope i did i should have asked
beforehand but andrew uh is the creator
of dadverb and he produces content for
new parents and young families from a
dad's perspective he creates videos and
reviews for a variety of family related
products including home tech toys baby
gear and gadgets for dads his goal is to
encourage dads educate new parents and
bring a new vibe to the world of
parenting as he blends the review videos
with personal vlogs his ultimate goal is
to celebrate fatherhood and uh and
elevate dad's voices in the parenting
space he's built a successful youtube
channel to over 100 000 subscribers
andrew how you doing hey i'm doing great
and it's andrew 2 rhymes with few see i
knew it
it gets it gets you
for sure i got it
i got it okay i am so excited and fired
up that both of you guys are here today
and before we got on today's show we
actually talked about 10 reasons we've
actually we've just discussed 20 reasons
but we distilled them down to 10 that we
thought that new creators needed to know
about so lauren the first one is
consistency is key can you talk about
that a little bit yeah absolutely i
think you know being new to youtube i
didn't understand that you know i i
would do like a block of videos and i'd
upload like 10 videos on the same day
all at once because i knew nothing about
youtube when i started right so i think
knowing that you know getting into a
schedule of i'm going to record and
picking a day even if it's just one day
a week i'm gonna post a video every
saturday getting into that habit of
having a schedule is super important to
being
successful on youtube because i think
consistency really is key because it's
showing that youtube algorithm hey we're
doing this every week we're consistently
putting data into the system and you
know i think that was a big failure for
me in the beginning because you know i
do a few videos and then like life would
happen right because you get busy and
then i do a few more videos so i
literally when i go back and look at my
analytics and youtube i have spaces of
like two or three months where i didn't
even upload a single video within like
the first year when i was doing youtube
um and then i learned that you know you
have to get consistent i had to take
this serious if i was going to be
successful um and started posting every
week and now uh for my guitar teaching
channel i post uh twice a week every
week
that is amazing twice a week every
single week but you you built up to that
right you know consistency doesn't
necessarily happen overnight like you
said but it is the build up to that well
actually starting a youtube channel
andrew as you know really means that you
have to become the jack of all trades
talk a little bit about this as it comes
to starting a new youtube channel and
what does this mean when you say embrace
being a jack of all trades
so it's wild because this this really
this realization hit me like just a
couple days ago when i read an article
from social blue book and
it's expected for creators to truly be a
jack of all trades and embrace certain
things uh one thing being copywriting
another thing being really good at
design
knowing how to photoshop thumbnails
principles and videography there's
lighting you have to understand cameras
i understand microphones there's video
seo i rank videos and there's social
media management right and then you have
to like sell yourself because if you
want to work with brands down the line
there's there's you know there are
things that you have to learn just to
sell yourself in
these are so many characteristics and
traits that like people go to school for
and people pay tons of money to learn
like i always do college for copywriting
right and this is just one aspect of
what it's kind of like what's needed
of a content creator today in 2021 so
it's uh it's it's
it's overwhelming at times but the same
time like you're embracing you have to
embrace so much and it's actually really
exciting just to be like you know i am
learning an insane amount of stuff and i
can
i can i can do it
so quickly now through youtube through
vra through through so many different
things and uh but one thing to
understand is that you you really do
have to
embrace that there's going to be a lot
required of you there's going to be a
lot asked of you um and and really
trying to
master all these things that's really um
that's really going to define you as a
creator is going to help
man and i feel like when you start on
youtube
you know i i view it as like the movie
credits on uh the end of a movie and you
see just the line of all the people it
took to produce that that's you at the
beginning right it is you being the
person on everything you're doing but
not in a discouraging way you know i
think it's so awesome to get to learn
all of these new and valuable skills and
we're going to talk a little more
yeah we're going to talk a little more
about that uh as one of your points to
in a bit andrew but man i think the next
one is so key and we went over this uh
one number three um that lauren brought
up which was to know your exact audience
and we talked about this inside of our
youtube 1k challenge um one of our
youtube challenges where it really is
about understanding your niche but i
love how you said this lauren know your
exact audience why don't you tell us a
little more about that
yeah so you know like i said i'm a
guitar teacher and i knew you know
because i used to teach privately there
there was a certain group of people that
i really connected with and that tended
to be people over the age of 50 and i
was like well this these people tend to
be ignored online because people think
like people who are older aren't like
technologically savvy and yada yada so i
said you know i'm gonna just tailor my
channel to this audience which meant
that i needed to when i do my tutorials
i go a little bit slower i make sure
that i repeat things a lot of times now
i know when someone is watching one of
my videos and they're like a younger
person because they're like you're too
slow you're talking too much like go
faster but but that's not who my video
is for my videos for an older learner
and and specifically because i do a lot
of music lessons so i do a lot of song
tutorials i'm doing the songs they love
i'm doing the beatles i'm doing you know
neil young led zeppelin i'm not doing a
lot of modern music and every once in a
while i do i do something a little bit
more modern i think i just did an rem
song and that went over well but
sometimes they don't always go over well
because they're out of the genre of the
decade that my audience likes so i
really cater my content to people over
the age of 50 particularly men who are
retired and we just love the same music
and you know we vibe off of each other
you know i have my camaro in the
background they all notice the classic
car and you know we just have a lot in
common so it makes it really really easy
to interact with them and i was just
like you know what i'm just going to
focus on these people and once i did
that i noticed that my audience started
growing and i get women and just because
my demographic is a male i still get
women who are on my channel i still get
women who buy my guitar courses it's
just i'm catering my content to an older
male audience but you will hit other
people as well so just because you're
focusing in on one person don't think
you're ignoring everyone else but you
really gotta speak to that person
and andrew you are you're really the
same way when it comes to your parenting
channel one you're speaking to dads
which was an underserved audience i
think online maybe you can speak to this
uh topic a little bit more too for you
knowing your exact audience because
you're a cool dad i mean let's be real
andrew you're a cool dad you've got cool
tech i mean when you look at your videos
i'm like i i like i'm sure dads want to
be you so what is it like for you to
speak to your exact audience and really
know who you're talking to
yeah i appreciate i try to be cool dad
but
um
yeah
i mean when i first started out i
remember like looking for reviews of
strollers or just things that you know
that you seek out as a parent and i i
came across a lot of videos of moms who
uh
they provided good content but they
didn't do it in an efficient way that i
would have done it uh and i just wasn't
finding that and i knew that there was a
whole plethora of guys out there dads
out there who were seeking what i was
seeking so you know i had the know-how
and i was like i'm going to do that i'm
going to do i'm going to set out to to
[Music]
you know be that solution um and and i
knew what they wanted they uh they
wanted precise quick uh with
you know lots of good detail and lots of
pretty things to look at because uh
b-roll is uh i i i emphasize b-roll but
i knew that those are the things that
they wanted and i tried to fill that
void
yeah and i think you did such an
incredible job when i watch your videos
i'm not even a dad and i don't even have
babies and i watch your videos because
they're so good number four though is
probably one for me that hits home so
much for a brand new content creator and
andrew you brought this one up and it's
really about not letting the numbers
define you talk about maybe your
experience with this and and why you
think it's important that as a new
content creator starting a channel this
year that to not let the numbers be the
thing that drive them
i put so much emphasis in the numbers in
my subscriber count and the retention
rate and everything and truly i looked
so hard into that
uh and i thought that that's what i was
because of that number you know 14 views
that was like the number that that
always hit me i i worked so hard like 10
hours on a video i got 14 views i'm like
that's what i'm worth i'm worth 14 views
and it took me a while to realize that
it's actually not like you're you're
creating content that helps people
and and sometimes it's you know it's not
going to have a mass effect but it
doesn't matter because going back to the
first point you're learning all these
things you're learning how to write
scripts you're learning uh new
techniques and lighting you're learning
all these things so just because it's
not hitting all these massive numbers it
doesn't matter because you as a person
are growing you are getting better
you're getting stronger and that's
something that like the numbers can't
can't tell you or can't tell people and
then you you you want to you know
you see the actual number because you
correlate that to success but you got to
look past that you got to look past it
and recognize that you are growing as a
creator uh and and i i like to equate
things to basketball a lot like you can
read a box score and see how many
rebounds assistant whatever they got but
like that doesn't speak to who they are
as a defensive player and and how much
hustle they have off the boards and so
there's so many things that that go
beyond the numbers so you're it's only
natural to look into that but
understand that as you grow as a creator
you're you're you're becoming more
dynamic uh and and learning so many more
things and little by little you're
getting better as a creator even if the
numbers aren't you know what you
perceive to be successful
oh man that that just hits home
especially especially i love how you
just equated that to you know players
and basketball and man it really is i
look at it too like when you plant a new
plant you know it doesn't unless you are
like me and you go to home depot and you
actually buy a plant that's already like
growing
but usually you've got to like put the
seed in the soil water the soil you got
to let sun hit the soil you know it
takes time and that doesn't mean that
the plants not growing but it's just
that the numbers at the beginning
shouldn't define you it should really be
about that output goal how many videos
are you putting on your channel and
speaking of videos uh we are in the
middle of our youtube 1k
challenge and i want to make sure that
you get all the details to the youtube
1k challenge also like this video
subscribe if you're not already
subscribed and i want you to check this
out real quick and we'll get back into
other tips for starting your youtube
channel this video is brought to you by
tube1kchallenge.com it's our free
five-day highly interactive online event
where i'm going to be sharing with you
the exact steps that i took to start
grow and scale my youtube channel from
shooting videos in my bedroom this is i
guess the first sean thanks vlog to
generating over 150 million video views
and ultimately building a multi-million
dollar home based business it's gonna be
fun so save your spot by heading to
tube1kchallenge.com or you can just
click the link in the description
all right we're gonna get into tip
number five but if you're getting value
out of this video already please let me
know in the comment section below what
your aha moment is so far and tip number
five is good content trumps video
quality lauren tell me a little bit
about this one because this is the world
i live in right now because good
content is king right so tell me a
little bit about this and your journey
in creating content yeah absolutely um
you know i have a video my most popular
video on youtube right now i think has
like 1.7 million views
and it was done with my phone i recorded
it with a phone i didn't have a fancy
camera i didn't have the nice lighting
and the nice microphone
it is dark it is grainy it is it is
horrible in terms of like videography
but the content again this content was
so good that my audience really
resonated with it and it gave them a big
win what i was going over in this guitar
lesson
and i think people just started engaging
on and it was actually my first video
that took off and it took
just for you guys who are out there
grinding okay this video didn't take off
until two and a half years after i had
recorded it so you just never know when
a video is going to take off but it just
it proved to me because it is it's
horrible this video i'm embarrassed by
the video it's so bad video wise but it
didn't matter to the people who are
watching the video the content was
awesome i still get views and comments
on that video all the time so again you
know there's definitely videos out there
now that are in hd quality this this is
not i think it's just standard quality
it's my phone and and people still love
it so focus on good quality content that
gives a win you know to your audience or
really help solve a problem for your
audience
man
so
so
valuable oh my goodness i feel this so
much because i love that too you said
you didn't even know that was the video
that was gonna be the one and i have
this one right now it's almost
embarrassing really it's on our think
media channel it's going viral right now
and i am like grainy um webcam i'm
literally like this close to the camera
it's so embarrassing and it's like it's
like
you don't want to go viral goes viral
and you and that was the video you're
like this one this one's gonna be the
one and it doesn't go anywhere and
you're like i don't know yes it always
seems to be that way right it's like the
one that you put all the time and effort
into is like what what but the one that
you you know i see that on tick tock two
people say that all the time they're
like i put so much time into this and
it's the one that they were like dancing
with their daughter
oh man well this next one andrew you
brought up and uh it really is that um
uh that you need to truly be passionate
about your niche or it will show go
ahead and talk about that a little bit
because i think this is important for
people who are trying to figure out what
their thing is and how critical it is to
really latch on to a good thing
yeah so i i i have you know friends come
up to me and like hey you're a youtuber
you know like what if i did this i'm
like well why are you doing it is it
just a one-off thing you're like into it
right now or do you like do you actually
truly love it because
when you when you actually like love
something you're in on it you can just
talk forever about it you know if you
really really like a movie it's really
easy for you to just be like i you
should go watch this movie because you
can rattle off all the reasons why you
like moving go fastly right but if it's
something that you're just kind of like
you know i'm in it just to make money
i'm in it for you know the wrong reasons
you get a lot of the bachelor right are
you doing it for the right reasons are
you in it for the right reasons uh
because if you're not
the content's going to slip right uh and
so you you want to you want to really
like love what you're doing you want to
wake up everyone especially if you're
trying to build this up to be your
future you want to love that future
right so uh you know
really like don't just do it for the
money or to make business or anything
like that like do it because you
actually love it you have a deep passion
for the niche and you can contribute
valuable content for that niche
and you know really lauren your story is
just so amazing in the idea of really
being passionate about guitar i mean
you're really passionate about guitar
it's not something that you just kind of
picked up on the side i mean you've been
you've learned you taught yourself how
to do this and tell me why it's so
important that you should really love
your niche
i think that's the thing that keeps you
going through the grind i mean i will
admit i honestly almost quit twice on on
my youtube channel because it is it's
it's that grind you're putting stuff you
know you're putting all this time and
energy you know andrew's talking about
being the jack of all trades you're
uploading videos you're editing videos
you're doing the research like it does
you know bring you down sometimes i'm
not going to say it's easy youtube is
hard work but it's totally worth it and
that passion
is what's going to keep you pushing
through when i get messages from people
i get comments you know from older
learners who are in their 70s or 80s
saying you know like this never made
sense to me but i watched your video and
it finally clicked that's what keeps you
motivated to move forward so i always
tell people like find that why find that
passion because in the beginning you're
not going to make a lot of money on
youtube eventually you will but let the
passion drive you because that's what's
going to get you through those low
points and keep you pushing and
uploading
yes it will it definitely definitely
will there's going to be ups and downs
on this journey i mean here's the thing
if it was easy everyone would be doing
it there's a reason why
you guys made it to over a hundred
thousand subscribers got that silver
play button and are on your way to a
million and then 10 million beyond that
if that's what's right you know and uh i
think this one the point number seven
um
speaks so much about why youtube is such
a great place and that is lauren's point
about building a community if there's
something i wish i knew
getting started on youtube it would have
been this first right lauren yeah
absolutely and you know the ways you can
do that is is to have community groups
whether you use a facebook group i use i
have a couple facebook groups i have a
free one and a paid one um but also just
commenting on your comments i literally
even to this day uh and i get messages
from people i literally respond to
almost every single comment that i can
on my channel and i get emails from
people or just even messages people
can't believe that i actually responded
to their comment so get to know your
people you're gonna find that the same
people comment over and over and you
know i did a live today and some of
those people popped on and i was like
hey i remember when you commented this
on this video and i remember when you
did this on this video people like to be
recognized and you know even when i only
had like 10 000 subscribers and i wasn't
like a big big youtube person people
just really want to get to know you and
they want to have that interaction with
you so you know when you get your
community tab make sure to put polls and
and get interest from your audience just
try to interact with them in as many
ways as possible and make them feel like
they're part of the process too
that is great and i love you two are
both part of our video ranking academy
community and before we got on the
stream i was like have we actually met
in person because i really honestly feel
like i know you guys because of just the
community right and just getting
like-minded people around each other
online i mean we have people that are
watching right now that are from around
the world that are a part of our
community but it's that one-to-one
interaction right it's that time you get
to spend with someone in the facebook
group or on a live show or whatever that
looks like meeting up at an event um it
just becomes this uh you know when we
get to do it together it makes it so
much better don't you agree andrew oh
yeah absolutely it does it speaks
volumes
and number eight andrew i loved this
point it was always be a scholar not a
student talk about this when it comes to
building your youtube channel and what
you wish you would have known is this
so
i always want to embrace the ideology of
being a scholar and not a student what
is a student well a student is a person
who does the assignments they go to
class they get the job done
and they learn what they need to and
then they stop
a scholar is someone who's always
learning they never stop learning even
when they reach the peak
they are on top of the of the world
there's still something to learn still
something to master still a way to get
better uh and that's something that i
always
seek uh and i i feel like sometimes it
personally it's actually affected me
sometimes where i
feel like i've got like complacent with
where i'm at um uh when i first started
you know i like 2015 16 there were like
creators like zach calder and casey
neistat uh who you know i tried to
emulate them and try to emulate their
styles and i was able to like mimic that
and learn what they did i was able to to
incorporate some of those techniques
into into my videography and uh i was i
felt like i was on i was on a good path
then i as i started to kind of like see
a little bit of growth on my channel i'm
like okay it seems like the formula is
working okay uh and then all of a sudden
like i felt like a weight hit me where
i'm like i just
i'm not incorporating anything new with
my b-roll i'm not i'm not adding any any
fun things to like improve myself the
content's working but like what am i
what am i doing i kind of got complacent
um so
and i just because i i stopped becoming
a scholar i was a student i felt like i
got this i'm being okay
um when i wasn't and i should have been
learning something new uh whether it was
um you know
some video seo or
um you know working on better audio
there's always something to improve and
the students will always find a way to
just be complacent but a scholar will
never stop improving
wow i mean aha moment like crazy because
that is such a valuable tip the idea of
always learning and really i feel like
every level that you go now you guys
have both crossed the 100 000 subscriber
mark millions of views you're learning
new things right every level of this
journey just requires you to always be
present and always be learning such a
such a great tip number nine though i
think it's back to the nitty-gritty of
youtube being youtube and that is that
youtube is a search engine so number
nine is that keyword and content
research is important tell us a little
bit about that lauren
yeah and and again going back to the
beginning you know i was just i was just
uploading videos because i was just
uploading videos i knew i needed to get
like videos and content on this platform
but i didn't really know like exactly
what to do uh you know and then i
learned a bit about you know seo search
engine optimization i saw some people
asking what that was in the chat and
just learning you know what are the do's
and don'ts what does youtube like what
is it not like and what is your audience
like too and finding the best keywords
to to rank videos you know video ranking
academy it's all about ranking videos
and getting a video to rank you know
that video that has 1.7 million views or
yeah 1.7 million views it's ranking for
something it's showing people are typing
in you know how to learn beginner guitar
chords or what's the best beginner
guitar chords and this video is coming
up and people are going and watching
that so you've got to know what people
are searching for on youtube that's
important because if you're doing a
video on something that nobody's
interested nobody's going to watch it
anyway you're not going to get any views
so you got to know what content your
audience wants but you also have to make
sure you know that it's getting enough
search volume so that hey if your video
does get ranked it's actually helping to
grow your subscribership and grow your
channel versus just kind of like sitting
there
wow keyword research is all that we do
here at think media i mean it's so
critical to every single video that you
do and i love that inside of our youtube
1k challenge
we taught them about the asq method
answering specific
questions and when you're doing keyword
research it is all about making sure
that you are answering specific
questions what are people typing into
the youtube search bar well this last
tip is probably for all of the people
who have a little bit of self-doubt
maybe you're uh watching right now and
you uh have wanted to press record but
you haven't gotten there yet and this
was andrew's tip and it's the worst kind
of person is the procrastinating
perfectionist i'll raise my hand too
because this is what i struggle with a
lot andrew tell us a lot why this is
what you chose for number 10 and how
you've struggled with this probably a
little bit as well this was me this was
me i i was the procrastinating
perfection i i had to
before i
uploaded my first videos i mean like i
had to get the right
camera and get it the right setup and
get the right lighting and it's got to
be perfect and drop money money money
and uh what's the best gear and you
don't know how many times i've like
looked up like youtube studio uh setups
and there are so many cool youtube
studio setups and i'm like change it and
change and change and angle this this
and it's just like it had to get perfect
and it's like i wasn't uploading
anything i wasn't doing anything so i
it's because i was i had to be that that
perfectionist and and it was and it was
just like delayed the upload time and
delayed the late it was just like i
wasn't getting anywhere whereas if i if
i just got it to be
good enough and i'm like just upload it
and then all right
learn from that
let's move on to the next one and then
like improve off of that and and just
make upload make upload make upload and
just do it just get in the habit of
doing that because you're just waiting
for perfection it's just not going to
happen so just
press record and just start making uh
it's it's never gonna be perfect guys
it's it's never gonna be perfect every
video that i've made on my channel i can
pinpoint multiple things where it was
something was off the color uh the color
grade was terrible didn't work didn't
like the edit there were times where
like it just rendered weird and like
there's a a frame that was missing and
it went black i'm like what whatever and
you know and there's going to be issues
guys and i i struggle with it all the
time because it has to be perfect uh and
to this day like i still feel like i'm
uploading slow um and it's because like
everything's got to be on point when
really like
the content can provide value whether
it's it's perfect or not like they said
it before some of those videos that
popped were ones that they were just
like i didn't look the best uh and i had
no clue but it it popped so
just get it to a point that's like good
enough learn from that and just go do
not be that procrastinating
perfectionist because it'll cost you
whoa i mean
fire on number 10 right there and
speaking to me so much because even
before this andrew i was like does my
hair look right did i put enough contour
on like you know all the things and it
just doesn't matter you know people just
want you and that actually is the bonus
tip and i want all of us to speak on
this and that is to just
be yourself when you're starting on
youtube yes it's about the technical
sides of it yes it's about making sure
you're making good videos yes it's about
always being a student but really it
comes down to putting your personality
on camera and just being yourself and
that's really what people want right
lauren yeah absolutely i mean when
what attracts someone to you versus
someone else what attracts someone to me
as a guitar teacher you know versus
someone else that that's a guitar
teacher it's me it's my personality it's
my energy how i describe things and and
and that's a great thing you want to
connect to people and be you and i think
you know for me when i first started on
video i was so worried about like what
everyone else was doing um that i wasn't
really being myself but after i did like
maybe 30 40 videos more of my
personality started coming out and i was
able to be more natural on camera
because you do yeah oh my god is my hair
right you know what oh i look stupid
holding the guitar that way but you know
you got to get out of your head and just
be authentically you because that's
what's going to attract your tribe you
have to be you you can't be anyone else
um and i'm saying
go ahead andrew just one last thing it
is if it's not apparent
between the three of us my video quality
is by far the worst i don't have a nice
big fat yeti microphone in front of me
right it's the worst but the people
watching this video are you still
getting good value are you still getting
the same good value
mm-hmm
yes hopefully
he's like maybe
yes
i love it i love it and i love lauren
your personality's even coming through
like you said with the cool car we have
people shouting out the ninja turtles
that are in the back i mean i mean if
the chat is any indicator it's like
that's why i put the ninja turtles in
the car there because people see that
you like the ninja or my dungeons and
dragon shirt like people see people do
see my t-shirts and they because i
usually wear like marvel t-shirts and i
get comments all the time i love your
zelda t-shirt and i'm like it's a guitar
lesson but they're people
so this is it this is my personality it
is the guitar it's it's i love classic
cars i'm a ninja turtle person like
that's me and someone else who likes
ninja turtles might see that and be like
oh my gosh she loves the ninja turtles
and that might you never know that might
make them subscribe to my channel versus
someone else you never know
yeah and you know we see that all the
time even like the be yourself of just
even me having to get comfortable being
on camera and just being myself and just
knowing that it's okay if you know i
gained five pounds it's okay if my hair
is not right it's okay if i fumbled over
my words and i you know messed up a
little bit because i was thinking about
the next thing i needed to say it's okay
if those things happen that's part of
being on youtube and just getting to be
in community and getting to be with
people but here's the main thing you
gotta start right if you haven't started
yet you have to start because all of us
you see how confident andrew and lauren
are right now this has taken years to
build to this confidence level to be
able to just come on live and answer
questions so i just want to applaud you
guys and we have so many people let me
know in the comments right now if you're
watching live or on the replay have you
started already have you already started
your youtube channel and i would love
for both of you guys to just give maybe
a word of wisdom of word of advice some
encouragement for the person right now
who's on the fence of getting started
maybe they're on the fence of if they
should even do this youtube thing or
they've posted some videos and it's not
really working what encouragement do you
have for that person andrew
man
just
like like what lauren said earlier like
if you're grounded in a purpose and
you're grounded in like a passion for
your niche let that drive through like
just keep i mean it's
it's fun that we get to create this kind
of content and it's only natural for you
to you know feel down at times it's just
i feel i almost quit twice too uh which
is
fun to hear that from lauren because it
grinds on you but
if you just understand that like it will
work your persistence will pay off it
will just grind through it let that
passion for your niece continue to uh uh
help you drive you and catapult you and
and and do the right amount of research
and find that one video that just you
just feel passionate about like i i love
that i get to create content for new
that like even even if it's like
i know the video's not gonna perform
well but like it's so fun that i'm the
one who gets to make that content for
them like it's it's amazing and i'm the
one who who gets to to
find you know
strollers and baby monitors if you don't
know that's the stuff that i review uh
and i love it like i get to be that
voice like you are a voice know that
that voice
is so it can be so powerful to people uh
even if you don't feel like that voice
is doing anything it can you just gotta
keep on going through and keep on
persevering it will pay off i've been
doing this for
five years it's five years of work
and i'm not gonna say it's been easy but
it has paid off it's wonderful like
i get i'm holding this right now like
this is amazing it's amazing uh
it's in your grasp guys you just work
for it like it's it's there it's there
oh man so inspiring and you're so right
you know it's youtube is a marathon not
a sprint right i mean both of you guys
have been working so hard um and and
lauren i'd love to hear your
encouragement for the new subscriber i
saw people in here i'm just getting
started one video up haven't started yet
so what encouragement do you have for
the people right now that are watching
who just need to hear from another
person that gets it you know what i mean
we get this thing and so what
encouragement do you have for that
person absolutely you know the first
video i uploaded um my first guitar
lesson i uploaded april 17 2017 and i
got one view i think that one view was
me checking to make sure i uploaded the
video so so when i know what it's like
to be you know to upload a video and
you're your only view i've been there
i've done that and and like andrew was
saying i almost quit twice myself and
both times when when i was thinking
about quitting i said what why did i
start this youtube channel
why am i doing this and i focused more
on the impact i wanted to make on on the
world and i said you know if i'm helping
100 people a day then i am making the
difference in 100 people's lives a day i
know that's not a lot
but i'm going to start there and i'm
going to grow from there and i i think
you just really need to focus on
what you want to do with the world i had
a business coach who told me you know
lauren you have a unique story like like
andrew was saying we all have a voice
and we all have a unique backstory i
don't have a degree in music most of the
guitar teachers on youtube probably have
degrees in music i don't so i have a
very different style of teaching than a
lot of those people and if i didn't get
the courage to do this and start
uploading videos
these people would never have that other
side of the story and there would have
been
at this point millions of people who had
would have not been influenced by my
teaching so i really think it's
important that you understand that you
are unique and you have something
special to offer the world and if you've
only uploaded 10 videos upload 10 more
okay if you've uploaded 20 upload 20
more
keep doing it
keep grinding it out like andrew said
it's totally worth it a couple weeks ago
i went to iceland for 10 days and i
scheduled out my videos and by the time
i got back from iceland i had completely
paid for my vacation just for my youtube
channel um and that's amazing so it's
it's totally possible for youtube to
absolutely change your life it has
completely changed my life and
you can do it you can get there but you
gotta start by uploading those videos
and sticking with it
i mean no better way to end today's
episode thank you so much lauren if you
want to connect with lauren or andrew
i've linked all of their details in the
description below and if you have not
already signed up for our youtube 1k
challenge then that is your next step so
check out this info if you need to know
a little bit more about it right now
this video is brought to you by
tube1kchallenge.com it's our free 5-day
highly interactive online event where
i'm going to be sharing with you the
exact steps that i took to start grow
and scale my youtube channel from
shooting videos in my bedroom this is i
guess the first sean thanks vlog to
generating over 150 million video views
and ultimately building a multi-million
dollar home-based business it's gonna be
fun so save your spot by heading to
tube1kchallenge.com or you can just
click the link in the description